what up y'all it's your boy here making
a building check me out on the bootleg
cab podcast new single on the way mo
rain on the way
bullet cat podcast special guest in here
my guy uh youngberg aka hit makers yes
sir yes welcome welcome welcome man
appreciate you having me of course uh
first of all we gotta talk about this uh
is this a new chain
um yeah uh
this piece i ain't gonna lie when um
when i left atlantic or i left atlantic
a lot of people like my peers and
co-producers like it was a bunch of like
people and close friends talking down
like man you know he's going to empire
like it might not work out for him you
know really atlantic was really the fuel
behind the fire that was keeping them
going and i put so much work in
that i just said it last year like like
around this time beginning the summer
last year i'm like yo for every friday
for the rest of the summer it's gonna be
a new release and it's gonna rain hit
some [__] and people were just
laughing at me and then i would put this
emoji up and then literally every friday
for the rest of the whole summer like i
had a hit that came out or whatever so
i'm like [__] i'm just gonna make it
a chance too love the chain yeah bro i
appreciate it i feel like tory lanez
might get emotional over your chain
man i don't know man
if he hears the story now he can
understand what's next he gets the
context yeah but it's like it was it
ain't never no no that shit's hard yeah
tori is amazing you know what i'm saying
what is what is something like that run
somebody uh all together like 260. jesus
man that's a real uh
you know
atlanta house no for sure it's like a
lamborghini truck on him it said
louisville real estate nice little four
bedroom in louisville you know what i
mean yeah i've been working hard though
in la that'll get you a 10. on the side
of the
405. nothing i'm moving from la i'm
almost done i'm building my house in
miami right now so oh that's where it's
at man i'm almost done with building my
career by moving in like august
something like that no state tax nah man
that's gonna be epic you don't have to
pay state tax you could i mean i know
the gun laws are way more chill oh no it
is you good it's staying your ground
it's all that stuff you know what i'm
saying so you ain't got to worry about
that out here is ridiculous with like
all the bs that's going on in la light
they got to figure out a um a happy
medium with the gun laws in between you
know i'm saying how they trying to play
it because [__] acting crazy right now
yeah it's crazy because like it's so
hot in l.a
and they make it so hard for you to like
defend yourself so it's like
but don't you like if you had a gun in
your crib like you straight though right
like i i i listen i'm not the expert on
the la gun laws i just know that um like
if you were driving around with your
piece yeah the master you got to have
your bullets separated from the gun and
the trunk or some [__] and it's like
well what if someone runs up on me and
tries to [__] no purpose kill me yeah
shout out to rants from 1500 nothing i
think he um linked up with some of the
the um sheriffs and deputies or whatever
i don't know i saw that i saw that yeah
i think that there there's some people
trying to kind of like like you said
have a happy medium because you don't
want like because you know there's
obviously places where you could just
roll around open carry and you know not
to get into politics people feel how
they feel but
there has to be a happy medium
especially in a place like la where
obviously it's an issue people are being
targeted
late not the same no more though bro
like i remember like
even before i think a golden era was
like supper club and all that but then
even before supper club like how i used
to watch entourage and be like man like
you would go to the w you go to
roosevelt you go to this spot and it's
popping it ain't even that no more like
i don't even know like
if somebody came to visit me like yo way
to go get some chicks like where should
we pop out i couldn't even tell you
people always hit me and they're like yo
i'm in la where where where where's that
at i'm like bro how do i be at the crib
bro yeah i don't go i don't know i'm
like yo go follow sean dickerson i'm
sure he's his ig page will tell you i
like rome yeah highlight room
good luck
good [__] luck getting in man so um
obviously you signed your situation with
empire about a year and a half ago yeah
like a year and a half it's on my
contract almost up and march is up um
and through that uh obviously you've
you've put out some dope music you uh
you got you got um
artists that you've signed under your
imprint yeah yeah you've gotten some big
obviously shout out young blue you know
yeah um i don't know blue yeah but we
don't know if this is we know it's bel
air i bought it because it said blue on
it so yeah and we know that he's
he may or may not own that a part of the
blue we don't know but shout out to our
guy blue ah man you know coming to
empire was was really dope um
i really wanted to like i said i had a
little like hate you know what i'm
saying with me leaving or whatever
leaving a major label system so like i
really was like you know what i'm just
in a position where i'ma show people
that the hits are following me it don't
have nothing to do with what's happening
inside the building internally or who
what ceo i might be working with or
whatever like the hits is following me
and my team and as you said the first
record that we did
that went crazy was the blue record with
chris
and change baddest i wanted to come out
the gate smoking with that and i really
appreciate mo guys he everybody over
there that record was it's like a
reoccurring record or whatever
yeah it gets played all over yeah still
the record was top 10 for 47 weeks out
of the year last year yeah so it's still
very much uh i mean
here in la it still pops up as like a
power every three weeks because it
researches so well yeah that's crazy so
that was a big one and then [__] we made
a bunch more out today so
your atlantic situation cause you were
obviously producing so much music for a
lot of the artists on the leg but also
you uh you know obviously put put your
single it was a hot box that box stop
box hot box style box close enough um
yeah i think the title kind of like
killed it a little bit too i remember
there were some awesome promo items for
that song yeah like we had made a box
that had like a little condom in
hennessy condo it's like oh whatever
your your vibe was supposed to be yeah
um so would you say that like uh
like when you were in atlantic did you
have like a song deal with them or you
had to like give them a certain amount
of music every um because i know some
producers have those situations like i
got a homie of mine who's got one of
those at 300
so this is this is kind of my situation
with my career um
at atlantic i had a label deal
i was vice president of a r
and um i had a song deal of course and
then i'm gonna be honest at pretty much
every record company in the music
business i have a song deal with them
right now yeah right now still i have a
song dealing empire i have a song deal
with um epic records i have a song deal
with atlantic records how does something
like that work
um when you create enough leverage for
yourself and you just known for
delivering records instead of um
positioning yourself to where it's like
i want a hundred grand a track or i want
50 grand a track or you might go in and
say all right but um i want 35 grand to
track but you got to get
like costco so they pay you so with me
as the way i produce if i was a 100
percenter producer or whatever then i
would just get all the money myself and
they would pay me for 30 songs up front
which that probably like a million
dollars right there whatever but
um the way i produce is that i have a
bunch of co-producers that i work with
it's not just one person or one man
operation so i'll go and then they'll
pay me for half of the songs up front
and then they'll save the other half for
my co-producers or whatever who
realistically might not be getting 17 5
a track you know what i'm saying so and
that's how it ends up being dope so if
my song deal is 40 grand at epic records
then i meet a new producer i bring them
in i produce something on epic they're
slated in the system at 40 grand for
that record so at the very least if they
like all right take me away when it's
like well i got paid 20 grand for my
record you could be on your first beat
and have a track record inside that
building infrastructure so if you keep
working without me or with me and keep
your foot on the gas you had 20 grand of
track yeah i do notice like um there are
some producers that
will not give the co-producers credit or
they'll be like the big name and then
you'll hear the tag but you won't see
like
i do notice that you give a lot of love
and credit to the people you collaborate
with hell yeah because ultimately like i
programmed beats before i've done all
that or whatever but i've done stuff on
my album i've done stuff on other
releases that have come out but at the
same token it was like
i'm just so creative and i just work at
such a high level you know what i'm
saying i'm trying to make 10 records a
night so like to actually have as many
songs and have as many things going i
think i had 227 placements last year so
it's probably not physically possible to
make 200 and something songs a year in
12 years and they'd be fired up maybe
fire and react and get plaques for them
and all that other stuff i just saw you
just hit a milestone was it a 100
million soul yeah you know i'm involved
with 100 million records sold um that
i've either produced a co-wrote and um
that's super blessing man i think
a a year ago i was at 70. so you had 30
million in a year yeah that's crazy
i mean 277 placements will do that for
you so yeah the numbers kind of match up
to that you know what i'm saying so i
think it's like 11 billion streams and
100 million so i get the plaque on um
when two days so you've been like active
since you were a kid yeah um
now was bloodline records and dmx your
initial introduction to
i guess the industry yeah pretty much um
that was like my first record deal and
the crazy thing about that is that um
you know the story like i started in
chicago with a bunch of guys that were
like well there's people that are
notable so i could say on books who
works with kanye that's my guy shout out
to my brother
i just saw i just saw him at the pusher
show yeah he literally taught me how to
be a producer he introduced me to g
roberson yeah like he did everything
with me he produced my whole entire demo
which got me signed a bloodline and he
was basically
essentially what i am right now but
actually he was programming and doing
stuff like that then but books were
basically had relationships with no id
with kanye with um different people and
my whole demo was produced by books no
idea
and he's a great guy and we still work
together like he's still my mentor he's
killing it right now yeah so like me
books and then back in the day there
were a group called uh lep which
transitioned to infrared
and they were like the street guys
behind us and um i had been a bidding
war like that everybody wanted to sign
me rockefeller ones how old were you at
this time
14 okay 13. yeah
so rockefeller wanted to sign me tommy
boyd wanted to sign me um
def jam just the whole dmx everybody and
um the crazy thing is how i ended up
meeting dmx was on
eve stylus
introduced me to dmx or whatever at the
time and the crazy thing is we ended up
um meeting at what these [__] want
from a [__] video set
at um
at paramount lot uh in hollywood still
to this day out there in l.a and i
remember it it was like [__] aaliyah
was there dragon dmx method man it was a
like a two-day shoot of crazy vibe i
meet dmx and like dmx
like they like trying to introduce me to
x and like back then i was like four
foot four like i was really like a
little guy and uh dmx is like ill shorty
um i'm gonna go smoke this and and i'm
and i'm gonna holla back yeah like he
had like a few chicks with him and like
open his hand had a bunch of cali weed
or whatever so he went smoke i went got
on the trailer and they basically was
like rap he was like rap for me and i'm
like alright bet so i rap and i think um
i kicked like one of the twisted tight
flows i said going up in the fence but
the same [__] like like on that vibe
and he was like shorty
relax i don't understand the [__]
words you said
give me a different vibe
so i ended up spitting another verse
which they went crazy for because i'm
like a little kid yeah going crazy but
like i had so many bricks in my raps and
all those stuff like i was talking super
street [__] and um left my demo
the next day i came back to the video
set and like dmx was banging my demo out
the trailer like loud like going crazy
to it and it was books with me it was
all these same people these same guys
and i remember kevin loves walked up to
me he was like man you ready for your
life to change i'm like man hey you like
your life about to change from this day
and then dmx ended up signing me the
bloodline records wow and was bloodline
through def jams yeah it's definition
shout out to kevin lau stand up guy yeah
man shout out to kev man i'm speaking to
kev man i got song deal with 300. still
look at this all these years later to be
it's crazy that i worked so closely with
tina davis who was like with def jam
right when i was a kid and then now i
work at closing
or whatever and it is what it is so you
met dmx you ended up signing with
bloodline um
obviously the bloodline thing probably
didn't work out i think like a lot of us
had hoped it would have yeah i think
that x just wasn't ready to run his own
company like that or whatever like he
was just too big like because that was
like uh
what was that before that was like right
before the the the great depression nah
yeah this is this is like because and
there was x was that was a that was that
was that that what these [__] want
was on that album yeah so it was right
out the in the midst of that album and
right out there i think this dude what
comes to mind is um i remember being in
toronto when we were filming exit wounds
with steven seagal and all that other
you were there yeah i stayed with x the
whole time while you did exit wounds
that's crazy yup i remember that wasn't
dragon in that movie yep drag was in the
movie everybody was out there like
toronto was crazy and like that's how
like another thing went viral when i was
promoting thoughtbox that's how dmx
stole my first piece of [__] when i was
like a kid like we had went to a club
and um like met a bunch of girls we got
back in the car like i remember i was in
the back seat feeling filling up the
girls she feeling on me whatever we
going to my hotel room i'm literally
like putting my key in a hotel and like
the man is like a dog in real life like
he just opened up the door his suite was
like yo ma uh
i think you love her person here and she
had never been to the hotel or nothing
and she literally left me and went in
dmx room and got a purse dmx
at that time he's you know the biggest
[__] on the planet yeah he's
like
man i don't know
what we say like equivalent what was he
like drake right you know it's crazy
because when i was a kid um going to
like the hard knock life tour i left
like you know i love jay-z but like
i was there to see dmx so dmx went on
before hove which at the time was kind
of crazy because dmx was the bigger
artist at the time you think they were
like swapping headlines no
because it was that was the i was a
rockefeller tour it was a hard knock
life too yeah
so i remember dmx performed and just
destroyed it and you know jay's um
stage
energy's different than dmx so it's like
night and day dmx just got done praying
crying on stage and before that method
man remember flying around yeah i went
to that concert i remember that yeah and
uh when hove went on like it was cool
but like me and my cousin left you know
i mean shout out to hope but i saw hope
38 times after that but
yo what up man we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good folks at blue chew that's right
go to bluetooth.com fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [__] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
blue chew it is the wave uh how about
this the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis getting delivered
right to your door in a chewable form in
discrete packaging and the best part
about it is it's all online
zero awkward visits to the doctor's
office zero you go online you sign up
with the promo code bootleg that's right
bootleg when you check out you will get
the first month for free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars on shipping and
you're gonna get one month's supply of
blue chew all right and you're gonna be
[__] like you were [__] never
[__] before your dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and sucked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com and use
that promo code bootleg and get your
first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg
on
bluechoo.com let's get back to the
interview
yeah um
so now obviously uh you you get through
the bloodline thing and then you start
catching a wave as
a solo artist young berg now that's like
i was iceberg then and within dmx era
and then i became youngberg and your was
your first uh
what was your first like big record as
young bird because you had a few sexy
lady was the big record that i started
here um who was on that hook it was a
guy named junior kind of like similar to
how like i create um a bun well you know
i've created a lot of records like in my
career like a bunch of the the singers
or people that were on my references
homies yeah like they were just people
that i were working with uh artists that
turned into artists that i would work
with as well um and i still do that in
my career right now like i have a bunch
of people that are i meet as songwriters
that i empower and uh their dream is to
be an artist so that ends up happening
but sexy lady is a crazy story because
um
remember club called privilege yeah i
heard of it yeah remember tk
who now works for hypnosis you remember
the promoter tk that used to do
privilege well man he did every crazy um
listen when sexy lady came out i was
like 18 as an intern in phoenix okay
cool so
i was um
me too i was like actually
i was about to say you and i uh did did
some clubs together some 18 and up clubs
in arizona during that round i was like
18 at the same time and the funny thing
is my weed man at the time
was a club promoter at the club and he
ended up um
introducing me to dj echo from power 106
or whatever
echo would just go and just like be
playing my record in the club and i used
to come in there like
super young kid
chinchilla on just walling out or
whatever and then we built like a
a group of people to where a community
to where like my manager would hand out
a clipboard everywhere we get everybody
emailing everybody's number or whatever
and tell them it was for parties but it
turned into being a number for them to
call for power 106 to play my record oh
[__] so i went and echo took me into a
mixer meeting at power 106 i didn't know
nobody and he went in there like yo this
record is reacting crazy in the clubs
this is this kid and they brought me in
at the end of the mixing meeting i went
in there i told my life story pretty
much i cried through the water works on
them for a little bit at the end and
then next thing i know it started off at
mcshow it was a light rotation and then
before i even got a record deal i was in
power rotation with that independent
yeah no that's crazy that doesn't happen
nah that was crazy that was like one of
the that was a wild thing i never really
seen it happen like that that's a very
you that's like a unicorn situation man
and with me not being from la as well
was even the kids right you're not from
l.a or don't have a label behind you
yeah that's a that's that doesn't happen
man yeah it's a crazy story so from
there you get your deal yep that got you
signed yep that got me signing epic
shout out to charlie walk katie welly um
my bro billy jay who still manages with
me now um basically
my bro billy j worked for john monopoly
and we were like in the same age and um
he literally hit up katie he was looking
for someone else that was working at
epic katie welley ended up answering the
phone katie was an assistant at the time
took me to keith naftali they came to
like one of my performances that i did
out here in la it went crazy and then um
[__] i got a label deal from there what
was the other record that you had that
all the [__] used to grind to i
played business the business oh my god
that was after see so it started
business [__] love that and still
love it
you can still drop that [__] like as a
oh wow
[__] like you were drake before drake
like you were singing i'm like bro shut
up bro no drake is drake i was me but
um the crazy thing about it was that was
after sexy can i yeah sexy can i was a
moment so it was sexy lady then sexy can
i so look how i get the sexy count i
record i think um you know ray j was
legendary i think his like little
he was just
he was a sniper back then oh my god like
i loved ray j so he's a real cocksmith
you know i put him on my uh ep
and then from there we ended up being
cool and um he hit me out the blue and
was like yo i got this record you know
sexy cannot you got you got the sexy
lady we do the sexy can i i'm like bro
you want to be the sexiest [__] in the
world yo how i'm gonna go from sexy
ladies you're sexy can i and i already
had the song of business right so like i
was thinking like i knew where i wanted
to go with my next record and um from
there
they caught they flew me to new york
because i was like i'm not doing a
record right
charlie walk i'll never forget it i come
in his office he's a president epic he's
dancing on top of a grand piano and
charlie walks like a little dude like he
probably like five one five two he's
dancing he's turned up to sexy cannot
play in a song i don't know if he was
like playing a trick on me or whatever
so he's like yo this is going to be the
biggest record of your career it's going
to be one of the biggest ones
and i was just like i want to do it he's
like what's going to take you to this
record i'm like yo call jason of beverly
hills and buy me an epic record shane
right now
and he called jason it probably came out
my budget or whatever but they made me
an epic records chain and then where's
that chain now um i gave it to one of
the homies i used to wear it back in the
day or whatever that's such a random
chain like i got an epic record change
literally have an epic record shame with
my face on the back of it my album title
and all that and shout out to jason the
beverly hills so in order for you to get
on sexy canada they had to provide you
with the epic records chain yeah damn
and sexy kinda ain't gonna lie it still
is it's like diamond or some [__] like
that like if you kind of like
i don't even know how to equate it and
add it up because the sales were so
different i think it probably sold like
six
million singles for real for real but
then you got to think about ringtones
and then whatever it was a bunch of [__]
going on yeah it was a different
different era where you actually had to
ring back ring tone i actually had to
actually set like i remember going to
the store and buying like
a signal on a cd
like that [__] was crazy yeah it had the
instrumental the remix yeah so sexy can
i was like it was a blessing though
cause um i'll never forget um
when we did the final record what year
was that 2008. damn yep yep so when we
did when we were finalizing the record i
wrote my little verses or whatever um
i wrote my verses like in miami and i
went to the studio with um my friend at
the time the girl who sang the hook on
the business cashier and i went with um
and and ray j we went to encore and ray
j was there just like after he did his
vivid deal or whatever so like he was on
a different level like he was
we've all been everyone's seen his dick
by this time bro he's in a different bag
so we go in there and like he's asking
cash or like yo um you mind if i play
these like these videos he pulls out
like dvds and it's like vivid porns and
[__] or whatever and like i'm like bro
play that [__] i don't care like you
know this is my different area
it's my homie like it's my girl like
she's saying this ain't no no super
duper relationship just like my best
friend so um
tiara marie was there with him and i
think that was his girlfriend at the
time while we were doing it crazy enough
and um he did we finished the record and
um
we went to miami we shot the video and
upon shooting a video like the first
take of the video i'm smoking up a blunt
it's probably like a roach we bout to
shoot the first shot i inhaled it once
and i throw it out the lamborghini the
police that were securing us on the set
came and picked up the roach and took me
to jail before the first shot of the
whole video on sexuality yeah we was in
miami because you threw a blunt out yeah
they took me to jail on a set of sexy
cannot i went to jail and the craziness
shaquille and ray j was partners and
shaquille o'neal ended up bailing me out
of jail and so i could come back to the
video i didn't get out of jail until
probably wait shaq bailed you out yeah i
didn't get out of jail until probably
like 9 00 p.m
so it's from like uh 9 a.m like i said
that's all night in jail yeah oh man
yeah i recently uh had a 24-hour little
jail sit down that [__] sucks
terribly using the toilet paper as a
pillow yo bro jail is not it it is not
it stay away ladies and gentlemen damn
that's crazy yeah shut up
um
and then obviously like i feel like at
what point in time did you make a
conscientious effort to
start branding hitmaker and start kind
of
not being necessarily the face of the
music and working more behind the scenes
probably like
i mean i was still after like because
you were doing like love and hip-hop and
[__] right that was after that after
that so like but sweet so
boom all that stuff happens and my
career i kind of calms down as a as a
rapper i i end up part ways with epic
records and then i was just lost in the
sauce for a while i didn't know i was
gonna just keep kept doing mixtapes i
ended up meeting dj ill will and
different shout out my guy ill will yeah
and then um doing mixtapes and then when
i finally made like the conscious effort
the first song i think anybody ever
heard me say hitmaker on was for a dj
infamous who's out of atlanta yeah he
had a dog he had like a um a collab
album and then i did a single with a
song called double cup it was with jcj
i was doing the hook performing the hook
jeezy and ludacris i remember that
record and um that was a dope record
time i said hit maker and that was a
record i delivered to him that was a
hard record too yeah yeah i remember
that [__] i think i was living in tampa
what was that like 2014 no that's way
before that i think that's like 11. i
must have been in vegas that was yeah
that was when i was in vegas i was like
i remember the song though yeah shout
out to infamous that was like 11. that
was like mixtape era juicy j
when juicy had the mixtape [__] it was
like bands that make you dance
like he was going crazy he was going
crazy so that's the first time you said
hit makeup
did you um because at a certain point in
time like you said like things kind of
started to slow down for you in terms of
like the young berg thing like obviously
a bunch of [__] happened you kind of had
a stigma attached to you how hard was it
to fight through that era of your career
because some people aren't built to
survive
some of the [__] that you had to go
through yeah it was pretty devastating
you know what i'm saying because like
all i knew was music like i said we just
spoke like i'm i got my first deal at
13. like right drop in your whole life
oh yeah i dropped out of high school in
ninth grade and so all i knew was music
or whatever and then to go through that
and it not be something like a lot of
the trials tribulations i went through
wasn't personally my mistakes it was
about me being around the wrong people
or me not surrounding myself with people
that wanted to see me win so to know it
was like it wasn't self-inflicted like
it hurt even more so
luckily i had enough finances or
whatever and my dad believed in me a
bunch or whatever and i just decided
like man
one day like they just don't want this
[__] for me like this [__] is still fire
but they just don't want it for me so
then i just switched the whole player
that takes a lot of humility too because
we were just having a discussion about
an artist that we both know
um who's a talented writer but
it's like ego's a [__] and it's
very much like hard to take yourself out
of the
spotlight
like it's like it's still your [__]
you're still getting your money off it
but it ain't your face attached to it
but i think at that point man i did all
the craziest things that i wanted to do
like you got that out of your system
yeah like bro like i've literally like
entertained seven women at one time or
just like you had to ate something yes
like wowed out bugged out stuff we got
to break it well first of all
seven women and you yeah
that seems like it could be stressful
um it was just a party
it was a party yeah like everybody was
like were you like lining them up like
i think everybody had attention on
everybody okay okay it wasn't like
specific to one you know what i'm saying
like it was no rules on it it was just
like we were all in you know like um
bang bros like they'll stack like ashes
on top of it yeah did you do that no i
didn't do that i was still young though
i was still like you got to think this
sexy lady sexy cannot raise your error
like you got to remember i was like 18
19. on explosive
uh on the chronic 2001 one riding dick
one licking my toes was this the case
for you
i'm not really a female type of guy
i'm not i'm not [__] neither am i
neither am i i'm not touching your feet
yeah no no no no no no i'll suck on my
i'll suck on my wife's feet but i i
would feel kind of strange if she wanted
to suck on my feet because i'd be like
i'm a grown ass man yeah i'm good why
are you sucking on my toes i'm good off
both i don't want to suck no toes you
ain't got to suck my eyes so you had
eight sims you gotta you kind of got a
lot of [__] out of your system so you
start um
running the behind-the-scenes plays and
it's so crazy because i remember
i might have been talking to
it might have been like
g-eazy or somebody
maybe in like 2016-17
where like i finally realized that
hitmaker was you mm-hmm
yeah and um
i did i think that was around the time i
did 1942 for ge it was before that
before that because i remember him
bringing you up and
i'd already known you were in that right
because that was a later record but but
yeah i i you did such a good job of like
because i'm you know at the time i
wasn't living in la and i wasn't like
going to studio sessions like i do now i
wasn't as like entrenched in like the
industry side of things so i just would
hear your tag and [__] and
had no idea that it was i'm like oh [__]
that was yeah that was that was
interesting i used to do like different
tags or whatever that was also a
struggle too because
a lot of people like when you're coming
up they didn't want my tag on that [__]
you know what i'm saying now people will
pay me to put my tag on that [__] like
approach me i don't do that but i've had
massive people approach me and be like
yeah you put my tag on your packet i'll
eat like 30 grand or something 450
but i don't do it because it's hard to
like not be able to explain a record all
these records i'm pretty much i'm
involved from the birth to the end i'm
the guy that has the demo that does the
demo with the co-writer that does
everything and then i'm the guy that
mixes it and turns it into the label so
i think man i was trying to sneak in
another time i got the hit maker [__]
off i did
my hoes they do drugs a record for king
louie juicy j and pusha t and that's
when pusha t found out that i was
youngberg still and i was hitman at the
same time or whatever and that was
another sneaky one the infamous one came
out and then after that i moved back to
la and um i actually
ended up beating vincent herbert and
this is when like he had gaga and he was
over at interscope and tamar braxton i
ended up working with her and did a
record with her and i signed my
publishing deal with mike karen based
off that and that's what brought me back
to l.a and uh
it's i was so i'm so disconnected from
the loving hip-hop [__] that was 2014.
so that was after you moved back to l.a
yeah so i moved back to la i produced a
couple cuts and then i was working with
a few different people doing a whole apg
mike karen move and then from there
um
i was at apg
well some life-changing [__] happened in
those moments i ended up meeting
jeremiah like like during that time you
guys have had countless yeah like under
mean jay
and then um
damn
like no before loving hip-hop
i didn't know jay
and i was just doing my my cuts and like
nobody knew that like it was no way to
be like man to to associate me with that
or whatever so um i actually um was like
[__] it i'm gonna do love in hip-hop
because i wanted to like let people know
that you that i was doing [__] and now
in the process of starting doing the
loving hip-hop that's when i um meet
jeremiah that's when um i was at apg at
mike karen studio and i'm popping okay i
stumbled across some of that beats and i
went and i did a hook to it and um i
named it nikki and hit hit maker and i'm
like yo i'm a neat meet nicki minaj i'm
telling you i'm finna start working with
it well i was just talking [__] hyping
myself up and then one day i go to
glenwood studio and um
a guy named sounds who's like a producer
friend of mine or whatever he i was with
him just chilling with him and found out
my boy was like yo nicki minaj in the
other room i'm like oh [__] go tell i'm
here i want to play us some [__] went
they came and got me i played or some
[__] and from there like i got really
close with mickey and just was locked in
so then i'm doing love and hip hop and
i'm like okay it's gonna really we ain't
started shooting yet we're about to
start shooting i'm like okay this [__]
makes sense for me to start shooting
this [__] cause i can just go and tell
everybody i'm working with puffy i'm
working with nicki minaj whatever and i
was so cool with them that they weren't
mad at me saying it on tv
was it um
like because i feel like the love and
hip hop thing can uh be a good in a b
like it could either be good for your
career or it can negatively affect what
you got going on because there is a
stigma to love and hip hop like how did
how do you feel like it affected your
[__]
oh
it was drama you know what i'm saying
but that's just come with the love and
hip-hop [__] but to me honestly like
because who all was on that on the show
at the same time you were on me rayjay
um was that when like molly mall was on
there and [__] wally mall soulja boy
little fears
oh
[__]
that is pretty lit yeah a little that
was like yeah think about it [__] that's
what that was oh marion so yeah that was
that first season and it was it was cool
i mean you know [__] at that point i
didn't have [__] you know what i'm
saying i was trying to get my exposure i
was somewhat trying to regroup i had a
couple cuts but you know how it is when
you're a producer and a songwriter
initially you'll have a couple joints
that were like
when a bonafide hit it wasn't like a
holy [__] moment you know and it was
just like okay you got a single you got
a couple placements or whatever and then
from there i ended up um
after that i left and then that's when
nikki album came out and what trackers
did you do for nikki
[__] want some more buy a heart
um shanghai
um i don't know i think like five
records on the pink
foreign fourteen yeah that's crazy man
do you remember your first like the
first record that kind of changed things
for you as quote unquote hit make like
that first plaque um well plaques i
guess it was that but the record that
changed my whole career probably is big
sean bounce back
and um i was working it's after loving
hip-hop i went on tour with um jeremiah
and um he was on tour with j cole and
big sean and yg and like i went on a
whole tour with jay and then we got off
tour and then i was just working with
jay continually working and then i
formed somewhat of a relationship with
big sean so i was like yo like you know
i want to get you records like i've been
already vibing with sean ended up
getting him that record me and a lot of
people don't know me and jeremiah came
up with the hook to bounce back or
whatever like we just did it at my crib
we were in the basement i had like a big
ass crib in chatsworth i bought like a
seven seven thousand square foot crib in
it by myself i didn't have much
furniture i was just in that thugging
with girls every day and i set up a
makeshift studio jay came in my crib we
did that record i played it for sean he
did it and he was like yo like i don't
i don't know like i like this record a
lot of people like it let's just throw
it out there like i don't know if it's a
single i don't think this
and um i'm like yo this [__] is out of
here and then metro booming added on the
record shout out to smash david who also
co-produ produced the record with me and
then from there he threw that [__] out
and and it was out of here stupid and
then it was in all type of super bowl
commercials and licenses and sinks and
then i think it was it performed his
biggest record of his career like sololy
by himself i think went number two on
hot 100 the [__] was like no that was a
huge driving time so i'm like yeah no no
what is uh what was that 2017 or 18.
i was like 2016.
wasn't it was it what happened was that
was that i don't know it was 2017 17.
yeah going into 2018 and then right then
from from there i ended up becoming a
vice president in our atlantic damn
so when you're vice president of a r
because like i get really i i think i
got a good grasp on like the importance
of an a r but i feel like most people
who just hear that word
don't really understand what an anr
brings to the table what they do what
the job description is because i see a
lot of people here calling themselves a
rs but they're they're not they're i
don't know what the [__] they're doing
but taking pictures in a studio session
exactly so what would you say is like uh
the the key role of like what an a r
like a good a r brings to the table to
me i think it's like
it's one of two things like for me
personally from what i've seen either
you're a person like me
who's a creative who's gonna come in
that if necessarily not gonna make the
record with you or whatever but is going
to be able to call a hit maker call a
metro boom and call it this person
whatever you need whatever you put the
right people in the room together put
you in the right place for this [__] to
happen for your [__] to be good
creatively or you could just be a guy
that just knows the building and just
going to champion you in a building and
knows how to connect all the dots off
that's not creative you know what i'm
saying so linking me with the right uh
video directly you know what i'm saying
just putting all the the in the building
type of [__] together you know what i'm
saying that stand on a ghazi or staying
on a craig cow man in a long raised face
or in a t in the davis face like yo this
is my art you know what i'm saying like
championing you inside the building
because it's kind of like two different
types of a r's yeah for real cause like
we think of like uh what you do right
you'll probably be like yo i got this
young artist that would sound dope with
this rider that might sound dope with
this producer
set up a session [__] me personally hell
no if i'm yo and r i'm
making the songs with you yeah but then
you're the producer of that yeah so i'm
pretty much your producer if you give me
as a i'm your producer damn
yeah cause i always feel like you know
we hear people say uh what the [__] does
an a r do i'm like it's it's a lot of
[__]
but it's also like
some people are just holding titles i
feel like yeah but if you and some
people that's because it's just a big
revolving door in the music industry as
far as like positions and [__] like that
or whatever because people have
relationships but to me
i would empower all the young producers
like myself or whatever like don't be
scared to get in the building be in the
building has been super beneficial for
me i talk to a lot of people a lot of
people be like man like um it might
stifle me creatively you know like hell
no when i worked with atlantic [__] they
bought my studio for me they paid for me
to be in the studio 24 7. so i really i
went to the a r meetings and i did all
the different stuff or whatever but
it was just like empowering me yeah you
gotta it's like any situation you got to
figure out how to like i don't use the
word finesse but kind of finesse this
and it's like if you can have atlantic
pay for your [__] recording studio
imagine how much more money you're gonna
get out of that studio and my deals are
not exclusive with only one company i've
never i've yet to do a deal to where
this is like yo i'm only making records
for this company and no other person can
pay me for a record how um because you
know nowadays um
i feel like the producer market is more
saturated than ever
um
it's kind of like djs once serato came
out everybody could be a [__] dj
right and i feel like nowadays with
production it's kind of the same with
splice and you know [__] like that you
know so
um if there's like up and coming
producers
how like what would be the advice you
would give them to stick out and to just
kind of break through because i feel
like there's
once you break through a certain ceiling
as a producer it seems like things just
start coming to you what up y'all hey we
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our partners the presenting
sponsor of the bootleg kit podcast our
family at odd socks man they're dropping
so much heat at odd socks right now go
to oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass
remember oddssoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
checkout let's get back to the podcast
yeah i think man [__]
be selfless you know you don't sign help
as many people as possible change lives
you know what i'm saying like put as
many people in position as you can
that's why i work with anybody i don't
have like a super like oh no you can't
come make a record with me like if you
hot and you dope like are you a
co-writer and you're a co-producer i'm
gonna welcome that in because it might
be a point to where i'm not hiding you
could throw me a bone i think it's just
creating a whole community around
yourself to where you can look back and
you change so many people's lives and
like a circle of successes like dame and
like they used to talk about it because
like somebody can pull you right up or
and make sure you keep your
relationships good with all the people
that you work with if you just starting
it would be dope in my thing it's like
if you could catch one artist that you
feel like is somebody that has the same
drive and mentality as you and y'all
blow up together then i just lock in
with somebody yeah that's super
beneficial too build build an artist's
sound that's all that's one thing that i
really um didn't have the opportunity to
do as a producer because i was already
operating on such a high level once i
was in a position that i was just
working with everybody but i didn't
really like well i'm doing that now i
feel like with tink or whatever and all
the stuff that we got going on but i
didn't really come up with one guy like
how uh also and you didn't come up with
tink nah you know tinkster she's
established
she's been doing her thing for years
yeah yeah but i'm just saying like doing
the whole album like how a metro would
do future or south side you know what
i'm saying all those different you kind
of did that with the you i mean i just
in terms of doing the whole album the
jeremiah ty wreck yeah which by the way
that [__] was so criminally slept on i
you know why i was [__] up two labels
yeah that's all every time it happens i
think that dev jam was kind of like in a
weird space at that time too when we put
it out and um
because i don't know if anybody was at
the the seat you know what i'm saying
remember like that moment where nobody
was actually the president it seemed
like for a while def jam was very what
the [__] are they doing over there yeah
it was an interesting time and then i be
honest the record that we use is a
single
the higher-ups that atlantic didn't want
it to be the single on the group album
they wanted it to be the single on ty's
album and i'm like nah like ty already
got hits we got pineapple we got this
when we got that one or whatever like
let's leave this for the group and i
think that they just both were i'm
interested in pushing it like i was and
that's that [__] is a fire great project
and it's crazy because i feel like any
time that happens where there's like two
labels somehow it gets like it just
happened with um
the the six tape two with bino and blast
i just talked a blast about this i was
like yo there was like hits on that
album
it's just
two labels
two mean cooks in the kitchen man too
many cooks in the kitchen and like
you know these [__] they're
like well what about your [__] yeah yeah
and they didn't like what we said they
wanted it for ty you know what i'm
saying like everybody when you think
about two different labels and two
different artists on two different
labels their intentions is to
keep the smash for them in their
building you know what i'm saying more
so than share a smash with another label
i saw was i think it was last year you
had uh brought up uh
averses against mustard potentially yeah
and a lot of people thought you were
absolutely crazy i was not no it didn't
just him well he thought you were crazy
um
and it was funny because when i was
talking to i was like you know what like
wow mustard
has bigger records where i mean you know
i'm in terms of like uh the rihanna the
[__] i got some big red
i'm not saying you don't what i'm saying
is i just thought that like
people didn't really dive enough into
real like realize like what records you
could bring together sleeper records
that people don't even know i was
involved with john by rick ross and lil
wayne i'm involved in that record shout
out to a.l producer shout out to my guy
from orlando bro like
he can
what is it 20 records i have three
records as me that i'll appoint and he
don't have any of those i have three
records as me that are appointed you
just said the business like people
[__] like come on i still have three
records as me like that's easy i just
think uh i don't think people were
giving you enough respect when you
brought that up um you know what it was
i think that you know me and him have a
personal relationship and we've worked
together and collaborated before so i
think that it probably may have rubbed
him the wrong way just for somebody like
because he's been dj mustard the whole
time and i was um i was
burg a [__] that was just in the studio
bringing him records writing records we
we got plaques together like i put nicki
minaj on his single like i've done
records with him but we had a falling
out of sorts because it was some bad
business that was done behind a record
and he just has had which record was it
um the whatever you need record meeks
meek featuring chris brown and ty dolla
sign and um i came and brought him that
record first like it was my record i had
the hook done aaron ray shout out to
aaron ray who's killing it yeah he me
and him wrote the hook on that record
the whole young lad who's a producer
that works for me right now we had the
same beat same sample same everything or
whatever i gave mustard to record and um
me and mustard have stopped working at
the time he went sold the record and did
it you know what i'm saying i remember
like fast forward to town i'm sitting at
the ass cap awards or whatever and i'm
sitting next to meek and all them and um
i won my award for dangerous or whatever
i think and then like they call me back
up there for whatever you need and i'm
like wait what the [__] this is my song
or whatever so i ended up hitting up the
the powers that be and shout out to roc
nation we ended up getting it squared
away so he just don't [__] with me he's
got this takes for me anyway so he
wanted to go and do that but it's kind
of like yo like fam like we all
multi-millionaires so that record
whatever you need was a record you
brought to him it's my record it's not
even with you brought to you it was your
record and then he sold it without
giving you any of the credit of a
thousand percent me and nra that's crazy
that seems like a wild thing to do in
2020 2019 what was that it was 2018.
yeah right 18. yeah it seems like a wild
thing to do i feel like there's so much
transparency like now it's like dude i
have the session bro like this [__] is
dated and i got love for mustard man i
ain't going yeah mushrooms are
collaborated we've done great work
together whatever he a cool guy i don't
got no b for him or whatever but my
thing was just funny to me because it's
like oh like
you're really bothered by this you know
what i'm saying like who am i supposed
to say i'm gonna do a versus with like
it's only a few different people like
what i'm gonna say uh that make rap
music and r b music at the certain level
do i make it so i was thinking what
mustard london on the track uh who who
can i really say that's in a tear to
actually be in a versus that does both
of those that's in my
type of you know what i'm saying yeah
that makes sense so i mean he took it
personally but i i know him so i know
why he took it personally and it's just
funny to me like it it tickled me a
little bit i think the versus thing man
i really think it's they got to figure
something out because they've lost some
steam because i totally did not even
realize the ugk eight ball and mjg [__]
was happening yeah by the time i
realized it happened it already happened
yeah they they gotta reinvent it you
know they gotta reinvent it i think they
gotta take it back to the grand man
they're doing it or they might have just
got the bag you know everybody's been
similar and they're like hey we had a
two-year run every business is not meant
to last forever and there's only so many
verses you can do last time i checked
the whole game plan is to start a
business crank it up and sell it yes for
real for real i think the only thing
they got to tr they got to try to do
usher vs chris brown
or they got to get like kanye like drake
usher versus chris brown but they just
did cayenne drake said we're not doing
the verses we should go sell out a whole
stadium yeah that's not happening drake
walked into a versus not knowing that
that's kind of how it felt on on tv i
was on vacation watching that [__] and i
was like oh
damn but you got it so i wasn't in my
you know what i'm saying like i wasn't
in a way and i wasn't mean to no
disrespect with that whole versus [__]
or whatever but you gotta really
this is the commentary of what's going
on in our culture right now i work every
day and i'm blessing my ass for this
[__] so it's kind of like dog like for
the last six years like there's not been
a summer off there's not been a not
plaque hat like for six years straight
100 million records man it's a big deal
yeah for sure so are you getting back to
getting on the mic no [__] no no
okay so you got new music coming though
new single on the way yeah down bad is
my new single off my producer album
still that's about to drop shout out to
the ladies with the first single thought
box on the homies that jumped on it and
then this new single like i was talking
about me working with songwriters that
might empower to be artists or whatever
that's just so fire to me my guy ivory
scott who um i brought into the session
and i was able to um help him do a
couple things that was big with empire
one we did batters together and then we
did he did peru oh [__] shout out to the
fireboy you know what i'm saying so
that's another way you could be a r2
technically i put ivory in a room to go
do peru for that record so um from there
he's on the record jeremiah and fabulous
on the record he's my normal
collaborators but man i ain't gonna lie
like this is one of the ones summer
smash video shot it's beautiful the
women were beautiful had like 30 girls
with me
man it was just good vibes
30 yeah
you gonna see it's it's a nice it's a
nice mix nice
not quite the eight though oh yeah
yeah i mean i feel like uh we we got
shout out to my wife you know i got all
that crazy [__] out of my exactly man
hey yeah super executive time man it's
executive time man do you feel like do
you do you feel like nowadays man like
like
because
you're in a position that
i think people look to you as like a
leader as like somebody who could change
an artist or a songwriter's life do you
feel that weight on your shoulders
nah it's happening organically like man
like i've seen an interview with dame
dash or whatever and like i used to like
i literally used to be saying this [__]
on my gram like yo the name of my
company is not trying records or not
trying llc because like literally like
me and my homies and my team we go to
the studio and it's not like we're
trying to make a song you know what i'm
saying or let's make a song for beyonce
today or let's make this or let's make a
song with taylor swift we just go in
there
have some drinks smoke a little bit and
just let people have activity flow and
like that just turned into 10 songs a
night 10 songs a night you do that for
years straight and then you just able to
load everybody up so
i don't know like i'm just what was we
talking about again what was we saying
what was the question again so i gotta
answer i'm just saying do you feel like
the weight on your shoulders they're
like you're kind of ah it's happening
organically yeah like all the stuff that
i'm doing or whatever like even with me
like i think i was well i don't even
think i know that i kind of like i set
out maybe four years ago
five years ago six
five six years ago and i'm like yo i'm
gonna flip every record that i love from
my childhood growing up and i'm gonna
make this sound i'm gonna be the puff
daddy of this generation i'm gonna bring
all these samples back and i really did
it and then now you see like ever but
it's turned into a thing now you know
what i'm saying so i just i was like
damn well i just need to follow my first
instinct so whatever feels good and
whatever my
my initial like reaction is i'll just go
with it for real that's tough man well
listen when's the single drop oh the
single 17th this month june finished
next friday yeah next friday for the set
this summer on fire you did when's the
album coming out that album's coming out
in september it was supposed to come out
when i sold 100 million records but
thank you god that happened a little bit
faster than i thought it was going to
happen so he's like [__] how am i ready
yeah it comes out in september man it
features everybody the whole game and um
salute to everybody that even ever made
a producer album salute to khalid oh my
god i said i just seen an interview with
southside salute to him doing a producer
i'm shooting man anybody to try this
[__] man this [__] is a nightmare it is
so many different
moving parts different labels different
legal teams management because yo you
might know the artist and the artist is
like yeah of course i got you but then
you got to talk to their [__] people
and then that's when it's just really
political you know what i'm saying is
just getting everybody on the same page
and a lot of moving parts so i salute
anybody that does this type of album
it's a great body of work we already got
one gold single with that box i'm about
to put out this next single get another
player wait we um thoughtbox isn't going
to be in the album though is it yeah i
took it off i took all the records from
atlantic oh [__] yeah shout out to
atlantic shout outs
with like [__] 10 chicks yeah i did a
remix with um dream doll mulatto um
chinese kitty drizzy and young young man
and the [__] went super duper remember
man it was bigger than a record my
initial record with the guys was a
boogie meek two chainz uh namir and
tiger i had them all on the record all
five on damn yeah i didn't it didn't
work out i think it was because the
title was called thot box and you got
five guys on the record you know i'm
saying i might move but when i i was
literally in in vegas
just turned up on a [__] we were
working this back when the palms had the
studio in the palms and we were just did
they get rid of that yeah yeah that was
a great studio that [__] was amazing we
was in there working just turned up and
i'm like man yo the single's not moving
like i wanted to move [__] it i'm gonna
go put all girls on the song but i'm not
gonna go reach for like mickey or cardi
or the the the top-tier usual suspects
i'm gonna get all the up and coming any
girl that got over a million uh
instagram followers that i like and i
[__] with their music i'm gonna go put
them on a song and i felt like that way
when they all press go at the same time
it could turn into pandemonium it just
it became a thing and that's what
happened there it is man album coming
out in september yes sir single out next
friday appreciate your time bro thanks
for pulling up man my guy